Good afternoon, my friends.
-Stillwater!
Are you enjoying this beautiful day?
Hi there, everyone.
My name is Mallika Chopra.
I'm so happy we can spend some time
with each other today.
Together we're going to be noticing new things,
making some music,
- Nice song, everyone.
- and even trying different ways of breathing.
(Exhales)
And speaking of breathing, let's start by
just taking a big, deep breath
in through the nose
and out through the mouth.
In
(Inhales)
and out.
(Exhales)
Breathe in
(Inhales)
and out.
(Exhales)
Okay, I think we're almost ready.
Before we begin, would you mind gathering
some things to help with this experience?
Can you find a comfy pillow,
a towel or exercise mat,
and a plastic bowl and spoon?
Feel free to ask a parent or adult for help.
See you back here in about a minute.
Do you have any old blankets?
Have a look in the shed.
Why, hello there.
Welcome!
There's room for everyone.
Huh, there now.
Have you found them?
Great, this is going to be fun.
Now take out your comfy pillow,
sit on top of it, and let's begin.
(Exhales)
Hello there.
Welcome to a Mindful Moment
with Stillwater.
We are so glad you can join us.
Did you know looking and listening
to our surroundings
can help relax and calm the mind?
You might even discover something new.
So today we're going to use
our eyes to be mindful...
and notice the world around us.
There's so much color in nature.
What colors do you see?
Green.
Brown.
Blue.
Red.
Grey.
Pink.
Ah, and look who added
one more color.
Can you spot the red trees and bushes?
Look at the birds soaring
high above in the big blue sky.
Do you see the ripples in
Stillwater's Zen garden?
Or the rectangles on his house?
How about the rocks leading
to his bridge?
And the arch shape as the
bridge crosses the creek.
Oh look, tiny footsteps in the snow.
Can you guess what animal it is?
It looks like a small bird.
Watch as the lanterns start to glow.
And the fireflies love to glow too.
Ah, the starry night sky.
Keep an eye out for shooting stars...
and make a wish.
Great job noticing today.
So, how do you feel now?
Actually, a lot better!
I think it's wonderful you've come out here
to be so present in the world around you.
Very good work!
Thank you, Stillwater.
I'm proud of you for trying.
I'm proud of me, too.
Hi, I'm Kishi Bashi.
And I'm Toby!
Hope you like our music.
K and I love to play music.
We had a chance to write music for Stillwater,
this wonderful show.
Had so much fun.
It allows me and Toby, you know,
the composers, to really
to have fun with the music.
And we really would hope that
you would play some with us today.
Would that be okay?
Would you like to try?
Uh, okay!
We brought our instruments.
Got mine!
Did you guys bring yours?
Do you guys have your bowls and spoons?
Toby, what do you think,
are they ready?
Let me see...
yeah, they, I don't know, oh yeah, yeah,
they got them.
Okay, so, let's make music together.
Toby you ready?
I'm ready.
Okay, well let's start with a beat.
Okay, so,
you guys grab your bowl and spoon,
(Claps)
And tap along.
And it's okay if you don't have one,
you can also just clap like me, okay?
So clap along because I'm going
to start playing the violin.
Ready?
Great job, everybody!
One, two, three, four.
-Woo, that was fun!
-That sounded awesome.
Great job.
Wow,  you guys did amazing.
You guys are all musicians here.
Now I have a question.
How did that make you feel?
Happy?
Calm?
Excited?
Sad?
Music can make us feel lots of things.
The type of music that I really
enjoy sometimes
is music that just invites you to feel.
It just, is this open invitation to
experience something.
I was about seven years old when
I started the violin
and I think I love it so much
because it's like singing.
You know it's like na-da-da.
And it's kind of like, uh,
it feels really beautiful to me,
so I've played it ever since.
K and I actually went to school together.
So we were growing up playing
music together.
Playing music with your friend is probably
one of the best things you could ever do.
There's like one thing better than making music
is making music with your friends,
and that's so much fun.
Hey Toby, why don't we play a game?
Sure, what are you thinking?
Let's try to name a feeling
and then make music to match it.
Interesting.
Okay, let's give it a try.
All right, well let's start with the
feeling of happiness.
You ready?
I'm ready, let's do it.
You know, Toby, why don't you kick it off.
One, two, three, four.
I'm pretty happy.
That melody really made me happy.
Toby, what makes you happy about that?
Yeah, the melody made me happy,
and...
the ukulele always makes me happy.
I like, the ukulele makes me happy too.
Ukulele's such a cute little,
cute little instrument.
I love it.
Should we try the opposite?
Sadness?
Let's do it.
All right, K.
Sadness, here we go.
You guys hear the difference?
Quite different from happiness.
It's a little bit slower
And there's some sad chords
in there too, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, sometimes
it's totally fine to be sad.
It's just, that's what we do
as human beings.
If we don't have sadness,
how do we know we're happy?
Right?
Every feeling you have
is just as important as the other.
So, it's okay to feel
any of those feelings.
I've got an idea for the next one.
How about excitement?
I need some excitement.
-Good idea, let's try that.
-Let's do it.
That was pretty exciting.
That's how excitement should feel.
Sometimes excitement is hard because,
uh, it's really fast.
So you have to kind of keep up
with the music.
So you're kind of running
along with it.
That's a big challenge for me.
I almost drop my instrument sometimes
by excitement.
I have dropped my instrument sometimes
from excitement.
So, that's the danger of being
too excited about playing.
Yeah.
So, for our last one,
how about if we try calmness?
Okay, that'd be a good one.
Yeah, I need to calm down here.
That was a lot of fun.
I felt really calm.
What about the music made
you feel calm?
It was like long and soft.
Nothing changed very quickly.
It was very slow and smooth.
Yes!
Yeah.
It took its time,
and there wasn't a big beat.
And, uh, it kind of flowed.
Uh...
Do you hear that sound?
Is that you, Toby?
It's not me!
Wonder where it's coming from.
Maybe you guys should go
take a look.
Yeah, go check it out,
let's see what that is?
Thank you guys so much
for joining us.
This was great.
We had a lot of fun.
-Bye!
It is time for me to scoop leaves.
Would you like to help?
Sure.
I like a clean pond.
And so do the fish.
Hey there!
My name is Jessica Skye
and I'm super excited for what we have planned today.
But first,
let's pause for a second.
Can you hear my wind chimes?
I love listening to that sound.
It always makes me feel so happy and calm.
And so many interesting things can happen when we just
pay attention to what's happening around us.
And inside us.
Like with our breath.
Let's try it together.
Remember that mat or towel you grabbed earlier?
It's time to roll it out on the floor.
Feel free to move your pillow
if you need to.
And it's fine if you don't have a mat or towel.
Just find a safe
flat surface.
Now have a seat and get comfortable.
We're going to take three, nice, long breaths.
In through the nose
and out through the mouth.
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
Two more and do it with me.
Inhaling.
(Inhale)
Exhaling.
(Exhale)
Last one.
Deep breath in through your nose.
(Inhale)
Heavy exhale through your mouth.
(Exhale)
What are you doing?
Stillwater says "if you have an angry feeling inside you..."
"...sit still...
"...close your eyes..."
"...and take deep, slow breaths."
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
It can make you feel better.
Great job.
Now breathing
is one of those things that we do all the time.
And sometimes we don't even notice it.
But,
if you're not feeling great on the inside.
Taking a moment to catch a breath can change that
and really help you feel calm.
Is it working?
Actually, it is.
(Exhale)
You ready to try something new?
It's called
deep belly breathing.
And it's one of Stillwater's favorites.
I like your big belly!
Me too!
I'd like you to put one hand right here.
On the top of your stomach.
Just below your ribs.
And when you breath in
do it through your nose.
And I want you to try and make your belly big
and full.
It's like
a balloon and we're filling it up with air.
And when it's full
go ahead
and exhale super slowly
through your mouth.
Let me show you and then let's do it together.
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
Ready?
Do this one with me.
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
Feels good, right?
Let's do it a few more times together.
Just keep going.
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
Super calming.
One more.
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
Nice job filling up that balloon.
Very nice! I think you're a natural!
Next,
I'd like to ask
what are some of the things you notice
when everything's super quiet?
There are many different ways to
be mindful in the world around you.
Let's sit for a moment and
just listen.
And I find sometimes it helps me focus
if I close my eyes.
So give it a go.
Soften your gaze or completely close your eyes.
And just tune in with all those noises around you.
I can hear the water trickling behind me.
I can hear the birds chirping in the distance.
And the leaves rustling in the wind.
What can you hear?
Maybe there's a fan
blowing air in the background?
A car outside?
Maybe your family are in the
other room and you can hear them.
So take a moment
notice if you can hear your own breath.
(Inhale)
(Exhale)
Isn't it wonderful?
Now let's
use our eyes this time.
How do we start?
First
start with what you see.
The shape of the fruit.
The colors.
So have a look around.
I can see...
...pink flowers.
I can see green leaves starting to turn yellow.
I can see a red table.
What colors can you find around you
in your space?
What color are the walls?
Maybe there's an object on a desk or a table?
What color is that?
Maybe even look outside your window.
Notice what you can see there.
There are so many colors in the world.
So take a moment
taking them all in.
Excellent job using your senses.
Now let's move on to something new.
Go ahead and stand up on your mat or towel.
Just like this.
If you got shoes and sock on
go ahead and take them off now.
We're going to give our toes
something to do.
All set?
Let's scrunch our toes up.
And notice what we feel.
I can feel
tingles in the tips of my toes.
What can you feel beneath your toes?
Is it soft?
Is anything bunching up between
you toes?
Maybe you're on wooden floors.
Or tile.
Is it cool?
Is it warm?
Now let's move up from our feet
to the rest of our body.
Do you feel the air around you?
Maybe there's a fan or a heater
and you can feel it blowing air
onto your skin.
Or maybe you stood near an open window
and you can feel the breeze coming in.
Did you feel the cold on your back?
That's my favorite part.
Perhaps the air in your room is still.
Try moving your arms slowly around you.
I bet you can feel the air now.
Just notice how that feels.
It's like the air is moving out of your way.
Just like ripples in a pond.
All right, let's do one more type of breathing,
and this is a fun one.
It's called "Bee Breath."
That does sound like fun.
You know how bees make a buzzing sound?
That's where this breathing gets
its name from.
We're going to buzz together like
little bees.
So let's take a slow breath in
through our nose,
and then this time,
exhale with the mouth closed,
and make a humming sound.
Let me show you first.
(Inhales)
(Humming)
Let's try it together.
Ready?
(Inhales)
(Humming)
Feel how your lips vibrate a little bit,
and it kind of tickles?
You can even put one hand on your belly,
like before.
And I bet it's getting smaller while
you're humming.
Let's try one more time.
(Inhales)
(Humming)
That's good.
Now I love how this makes me feel.
It relaxes me and it also energizes me.
How does it make you feel?
How does your face, and tummy, and chest
feel now?
It's always important to notice
how you're feeling.
Both on the inside and the outside.
And if you're feeling happy
on the inside,
that's wonderful.
And if you're not,
that's okay.
But if you take a moment to breathe,
it can make you feel a whole lot better.
Isn't it interesting how these feelings change
when you give them time?
Thank you so much for sharing
this part of your day with me.
See you!
Welcome back.
I am so happy that you decided
to spend time with us today.
And I hope you're feeling happy and excited
to discover what the rest of the day brings.
I'm going to try new things
all the time now.
And if you ever want to experience this again,
just remember,
you can take a deep breath...
(Inhales)
(Exhales)
make some music...
or notice something new.
Hey! Look at this!
There's much to discover in stillness.
Most of all,
stay curious about the world,
and express gratitude for everything
wonderful around you.
It's time to go now,
but hopefully we see each other again soon.
Goodbye!
Bye!
Thank you for letting me join you.
Let's do it again.